字幕: Shizuku Ogo
校正: Hiroko Kawano
人はなぜ悩むのでしょうか？
そのことについて ずっと考え続けてきました
いま僕の結論としては 人は「か」だから悩む
「か」ではなくて「と」の世界になったら
その悩みは消えていく
そういうような経験を
皆さんに共有したいなと思います
僕は 両親が台湾出身で
京都で生まれ育ちました
何不自由なく 何の疑問もなく
日本人として育ってきたんですけども
あるとき 小３くらいのときですね
正月休みが明けたときに
クラスのみんなが集まって話をしている
そのときに おじいちゃまとか
おばあちゃまの家に行って
お雑煮を食べておもちが丸かったの とか
いやうちは四角だったよとか
いうふうに言うんですね
「ちょっと待てよ」と
「いや うちお雑煮って
食べたことないねんやけど」って
「おもちって何？お雑煮に
入ってるもんなん？」みたいな
「あれ 僕ずっと日本人やと思って過ごして
きたけども 日本人じゃないのかな？」って
でも 例えば台湾に行って
両親の親戚や家族 友だちに会って
台湾語を喋れるわけでもない
中国語を喋れるわけでもない中で
「あれ 自分は台湾人でもないのかな？」と
自分は日本人なのか 台湾人なのかという
「か」にすごく苦しめられてきました
いま日本で仕事をして
そしてそれを台湾でも仕事をするようになると
「自分は日本人でもあり
台湾人でもある」ということに
すごく大きな価値がある
ということに気づきました
僕は台湾で講演をするときに必ず
(台湾語の自己紹介)
というふうに言うんですけども これは
「私のお父さんお母さんは台湾人です
台湾語をちょっと喋れます
でも日本で生まれました」
これを一言いうだけで
皆さんすごく笑ってくれて
やりやすくなるんですね
日本人であり 台湾人であるという
「と」の価値が自分にはあるんだ
ということにすごく救われました
日本人なのか 台湾人なのか
というふうな「か」で悩み苦しみ
そして日本人と台湾人とという
「と」の世界に救われたんですね
僕は２年前まで医学生として
医学を勉強していたんですけども
初めて 病院に医学生として
勉強を始めたときに
自分は患者さんの立場で見たらいいのか
それとも医師の立場で見たらいいのか
その「か」に悩みました
医師の立場として見るには
あまりにも経験や知識が足りない
でも 患者さんの立場で見るにしても
別にその病気を自分が
経験しているわけでもないし
その家族でもない
どこに自分の価値があるんかな
ということに悩みました
それが 「あ ちょっと待てよ」と
患者さんの立場も持っているし
医師の立場も持っている
その視点をどちらも持っている
ということの価値が
医学生にはあるということに
気づいたんですね
例えば 患者さんには
医師には言えないけども
回ってくる医学生 学生さんぐらいには
言えるみたいなことがあるんです
逆もまたしかりで 医師の方も
患者さんには直接的過ぎて言えないけれども
医学生には教えられるみたいなことがある
その両方の立場と視点と考えを持ちうることが
医学生の大きな価値なんだと気づきました
患者と医師とどちらの視点を
持てばいいのかということから
患者と医師とどちらの視点も持てるという
医学生の価値に気づいたんですね
また今 僕は名古屋のある病院で
医師として働いていますけれども
どういう医療をやるか
それをどうやるかということに関して
どう決めていくものなのでしょうか？
医療の意思決定とはどういうふうに
されていくものなのでしょうか？
患者さんが決めるのか 医師が決めるのか
というようなシーンがいっぱいあります
例えば 乳がんの若いお母さん
10歳くらいの子どもがいる人の場合で言うと
医師がこの人に対して手術をするか
薬をするかということに対しては
例えばこのがんがどれくらい進行しているか
転移はあるか 他の症状はないか
そういった客観的なものを
ベースに考えるんですね
でも一方で患者さんに聞いてみると
そういった客観的なものではなくて
むしろ主観的なもの
自分がもし 手術を受けて
おっぱいがなくなったら
初めて自分の子どもを
息子をお風呂に入れるときに
自分のないおっぱいについて
どう説明したらいいですか？
ここから入るんですね
医師は 客観的なものから
考えるかもしれません
でも 主観的なものを患者さんは
より大事にするっていう中で
患者さんが決めるのか
医師が決めるのかということが
すごく問題になります
そこを 患者さんと医師とが
どう一緒に決めることができるのかということを
僕らは考えないといけないと思います
それは 「何をやるか」
「何をやらないか」ではなくて
「それをなぜやるか」
そして「なぜやらないか」ということを
お互いに共有しながら
話し合って決めていくことです
その結論が 手術になるか 薬になるかが
大事なことではありません
その決めていく過程を
患者さんと医師が一緒に共有していく
そういうことに意味があるんです
だから 患者さんか医師かではなくて
患者さんと医師とが医療 どういう医療を
受けるかっていうのを決めていく
そういう必要が僕はあると思います
また これからの世代を生きる僕たちは
どんな仕事に就いていっても
AIというものについて
無関係ではいられないと思います
いろんな新聞やニュース記事を紐解けば
「AIが人の仕事を奪う」
「人はAIによって置き換わる」
医師もそうです
「AIは 医師の仕事を奪っていくだろう」
「医師はAIに代替される」
そういう話ばっかりですね
いわゆる AIか医師かの話が
いっぱいあると思います
ディープラーニングの父と呼ばれる
ジェフェリー・E・ヒントン教授はですね
2016年 『ニューヨーカー』
という雑誌のコラムに
画像をベースにして判断する
放射線科医という医師は
もうその育成をやめるべきだ
というふうに書いているんですね
なぜなら AIがすべてを代替できるから
というふうに言っています
まさに彼も AIか医師かというような
世界観で生きていたのかなと思います
ただ実は その１年後に
ジェフェリー・E・ヒントン教授は
同じ『ニューヨーカー』の雑誌に
コラムを寄せています
「医師の役割は進化するんだ」と
単なる画像を見る人からそれ以上のものに
進化していくというふうに言っています
僕たちが考えないといけないのは
AIか医師か AIか人か ではなくて
AIと医師とを どういうふうに
繋いでいくことができるか
AIと人とをどうやって繋いで
新たな価値を生んでいくか
それを僕たちは考えないといけない
というふうに思います
また 新しいお札の肖像画になる
渋沢栄一さんという人がですね
数百社の会社を作る支援をする中で
「会社経営とは何か？」
というような本を書いています
そのタイトルが『論語か算盤』ではなくて
『論語と算盤』なんですけども
会社経営とは算盤をはじきながら
利益を追求していかないといけない
なぜなら 利益を追求していかないと
会社はつぶれてしまうから
一方で 『論語』のような
哲学や道徳や価値観に
基づいたものをベースに
「この会社がどういう
社会的な価値を生み出すのか？」
「どういう役割を担うか？」
ということを考えないと
存在する意義がないと言っているんですね
『論語か算盤』ではなくて
『論語と算盤』であるということが大事です
僕もある医療系のキャンペーンですね
クラウドファンディングという
いろんな人からお金を集めて
何か啓発キャンペーンをやる
ということをやったんですけども
「医学系のキャンペーンで
お金を集めるとは何事や？」と
「お前はお金のためにやってんのか？」
というように言われたことがあります
それって僕たちは もしかしたら
お金のためか 人のためか 社会のためかって
どれかしか実現できないと
思ってるんじゃないでしょうか？
生きていくためにはお金が必要です
でも一方で それを何のために使うのか
っていうことも同時に考える
『論語か算盤』ではなくて
『論語と算盤』ということを
僕たちは実践していかないと
いけないじゃないかと思います
ここ数年 —
僕は今26歳なんですけども —
同世代の何人かが自ら命を絶ちました
彼らのことを思うと
「生きるか死ぬか」という
「か」にすごく苛まれて
追い詰められて 追い立てられたんじゃないかな
というふうに思います
シェイクスピアの有名な言葉でも
「生きるか死ぬか それが問題だ」
というふうな言葉がありますが
「生きるか死ぬか」
それが本当に問題なのでしょうか？
僕は「生きるということ」と
「死ぬということ」が
共にあるあり方が
あるんじゃないかと思います
生きづらさを抱えて
あるところでは生きていけない —
苦しい つらい 死にたい 消えてしまいたい
と思うことがあるでしょう
ただ それでも そこの自分が死んだとしても
他で生きている —
名前を変えてもいいし
今までのすべてを捨ててもいいし
でも そこでも どこかでは生きている
そういった「生きるということ」と
「死ぬということ」が
どちらかではなくて どちらともある
そういうあり方が僕はあるんじゃないかな
というふうに思っています
なぜ「か」が「と」になることで
新たな価値が生まれるのでしょうか？
それは「か」という世界の中では
交わらず 分断され
どちらかしか選べなかったものが
「と」の中では お互いが繋がり
そしてどちらの性質も持ち
そして重なり合ったところに
新たな価値が 新たな分野が 新たな概念が
生まれるからだと思います
そうした「と」には
間をつないで その間から
新しいものを生み出していく
そんな力があるんだと思います
この「間」という字
僕たちにはすでに備わっている
言葉じゃないかなと思います
僕たちは人間です
人でもありますけども 人間でもあります
人は１人かもしれないし
１人で生きていかないといけない
ときもあるかもしれないけれども
何かと何かの間に立って それを繋いでいく
そういった存在であるということが
この人間という言葉に
含まれているのじゃないかと
僕はそれを見出したいと思います
そんな何かと何かとの間を繋いで
「か」の世界ではなくて「と」の世界を
ともに同じ人間として ともに作っていく
そんな仲間になってください
ありがとうございました
（拍手）